hello and welcome to big Fink live
I'm Jason gots and I'm here today with
Matt Hudson he's the author of the seven
laws of magical thinking how irrational
beliefs keep us happy healthy and sane
Matt welcome to the program thank you
for having me you say in your book that
we all believe in magic luck mind over
matter
destiny jinxes life after death evil and
heavenly helpers even when we say we
don't how is that the case well magical
thinking relies on very basic cognitive
tendencies that we all share
so for instance we tend to see patterns
in the world and read meaning into those
patterns this is basically how we learn
and sometimes we read meaning into
patterns where there is no inherent
meaning so we see faces in the clouds or
we hear messages and records played
backwards and one type of pattern that
we read meaning into is seeming
correlations between our things inside
our heads and things outside in the
world so if the thought matches up with
some event then you see a correlation
and perhaps causation so let's say you
think about something and then it
happens you might think that your
thought caused that event or maybe your
thought was a premonition of the event
or maybe something happens in your life
that has some particular meaning for you
you might think that the event happened
because it had meaning for you because
it was meant to improve your life
somehow or perhaps it was meant as a
sign directed for you but you know if we
you know rationally
analyze these patterns like if we're
very careful and we sort of you know
think about our thinking and say okay I
you know I thought that for a moment I
felt that there was a correlation
between those things but does that
really make sense I mean is it not
possible to dispel all of those or most
of those kinds of magical beliefs sure
it's possible to dispel them a lot of
our intuitions are wrong we we have a
lot of cognitive biases and heuristics
we make shortcuts and of course it's
possible to use rationality and to use
things that you know about the world to
question your intuitions
to second-guess them and this is
sometimes called skepticism sometimes
called critical thinking or science so
at one point in your book you give a
definition of magical thinking like this
we instinctively treat the mind as
though it had physical properties and we
treat the physical world as though it
had mental properties
what is the evolutionary logic for this
mingling of mind and matter
well one cause of us seen the natural
world as being as having elements of
mind is our tendency to anthem'
amorphize things so we see things that
aren't alive as alive or we see natural
events as being caused by living
thinking beans and it's because we were
biased to see life in the world because
you don't want to miss animals or people
who could help you or it could who could
harm you so for instance one
anthropologist says that it's better to
mistake a boulder for a bear than to
mistake a bear for a boulder you
definitely don't want to miss that and
so you you know you might see your
laptop as if it crashes you'll yell at
it as if it's as if it meant to do that
or if there's a rustle in the bushes you
might see it as no perhaps an animal
caused it or let's say some event
happened in your life that has some
meaning for you and you can't blame it
on a person or on it on an animal you'll
seek out some sort of other intentional
mind out there whether it's a spirit or
or God or just just the universe in
general you write that the same magical
thinking that leads to sentimentality
altruism and self efficacy can also lead
to vilification fatalism and irrational
exuberance or even depression
obsessive-compulsive disorder and
psychosis in other words magical
thinking can have both positive and
extremely negative consequences so can
you explain your attitude toward magical
thinking and what it is that you hope to
accomplish by studying it well my my
primary goal in studying magical
thinking is to understand the cause of
it to understand why it's so common
beyond that I'm also interested in the
possible benefits and drawbacks so you
might think that allusions are
necessarily bad and it's good to have a
completely realistic picture of the
world but to me the more surprising
aspect was that it's occasionally good
to have these illusions and magical
thinking can be can be beneficial even
if it's not an accurate picture of
reality you focus on what you call
shadow beliefs those beliefs that we
don't really even think of as magical
and some are even quite banal but these
are beliefs that guide us through the
world every day I'd like to ask you
about some of the various categories of
these beliefs let's start with objects
can you tell us about the beanie baby
that you slept with for 80 years and
what it meant to you to lose him sure so
I had this beanie baby that I bought
when I I spent the summer in Alaska when
I was 18 right after high school and
when I got to Anchorage I bought this
little stuffed red dragon and I kept him
with me while I was up in Alaska during
this sort of it was an important summer
for me I did a lot of growing that
summer and I kept him with me for the
next eight years of my life sleeping
with him every night and then one night
he ran away from me
basically I lost him and I could have of
course tried to find another similar
beanie baby but it just wouldn't be the
same there was something special about
that particular beanie baby who I named
blip and that's because we we treat
objects as if they are special because
of their their histories their
particular histories so you might think
that there's some sort of non-physical
essence that's part of an object so this
is why people value celebrity
memorabilia or family heirlooms or why
you'd feel differently about wearing a
clean sweater that had been worn by a
serial killer versus one that had been
warned by a significant other
it's as if somehow the the objects
particular history or perhaps the people
who have touched the object is somehow
embedded in it as some sort of non non
physical essence
how do you sort out which or how do you
even begin to go about sorting out which
superstitions you know are valuable and
which are not like which we ought to
keep and which we ought to try to work
to get rid of yeah so it's it's very
difficult trying to suss out which
superstitions are good for you and to
what degree and in which situations you
should use magical thinking I would say
that in a very general rule of thumb
would be to look at whether not focus on
whether a particular illusion is or
whether a particular intuition or belief
is an accurate picture of reality but to
wonder whether it's a useful picture of
reality so is it is it changing your
behavior in ways that you think is
helpful for you or for the people around
you okay you write about non-human
agents such as pets who we talk to and
substitute for real people and even over
attribute certain mental capacities too
why do we do this and how do we draw the
line between what's normal and what is
crazy cat lady territory so yeah it's
it's this bias to anthropomorphize
things that leads us to treat inanimate
objects as alive or to read things that
are alive to treat things that are alive
like pets as if they are more conscious
or more intelligent than they actually
are and so you can become a crazy cat
lady if you abandon actual people in
your environment and just focus on on
your pets or your stuffed animals or
your live doll or whatever you have but
it can also be helpful there's research
showing that pets increased people's
mental and physical health and
well-being and I actually visited a VA
hospital in DC where they made use of
this robotic baby seal it's a six
thousand dollar robot that's white and
fluffy and and the people at the
hospital they hold it in their laps and
it it purrs and it responds to your
touch and these guys they knew that it's
just a robot they know that it's not
alive but still they're their magical
thinking and
anthropomorphizing leads them to treat
it as if it's a real companion and they
speak to it and it and it helps them in
it and it gives them comfort
speaking of robots we're increasingly
dealing with voice-activated software
like Siri and you know computers that
are talking back to us and so on so how
does some you know how does this kind of
magical thinking enter into those
interactions and how can we make our
relationship with these new technologies
most beneficial or do you have any
thoughts on that well we're very social
species we've evolved to interact with
other people we haven't evolved to
interact with computers and so rather
than trying to reprogram our brains to
try to think in code or to try to you
know understand silicon it makes more
sense to try to program computers to
behave more like people so that we can
interact more fluidly with them we want
to broach the topic of religion you note
it you know in your book that only 16%
of Americans believe humans evolved with
no magical or divine intervention and
quote Richard Dawkins who wrote it's
almost as if the human brain were
specifically designed to misunderstand
Darwin and to find it hard to believe
why do humans default to the belief that
we are part of a grand design well in
part this relies on our our general bias
to read intentionality into things to
see things as happening for a reason to
believe that objects that are around us
have been designed for some purpose this
is called teleological reasoning we're
especially likely to do this when we see
something that has a lot of order to it
so for instance humans you know you if a
bunch of particles just got together and
like fell together into a pile and it it
turned into a human you'd be very
surprised so you know it seems like
there should be some sort of organism or
intentionality that would arrange these
things and so that's just our our bias
or
it's a very good rule of thumb generally
because of entropy order dissipates
so whenever order comes together
it's often because someone or something
put it that way while you say that
everyone uses magical thinking what do
you see as the key difference between
skeptics and non skeptics well skeptics
and non skeptics are are very similar in
a lot of ways we all share the same
intuitions we all have the same instinct
for magical thinking and people who are
less superstitious are actually not
necessarily more intelligent or more
educated than other people it's really
that they have a tendency to question
their intuitions so it's partly
motivation partly habits if you're more
motivated to try to get down to the the
basics and try to figure out ok what's
real and what isn't or if you've done
this a lot and it becomes second nature
just through a habit of questioning
their beliefs and questioning your
perceptions and questioning and
illusions then you're more likely to be
become a skeptic I mean yet while we
might not be able to say that it's a
question of intelligence you know the
difference I guess would you say that
intentionality and awareness with
respect to our own superstitions and
magical thinking is important and useful
in terms of deciding and trying to sort
of figure out and guide our own
consciousness in the ways that are
beneficial to us sure yeah
so I before that often it's more
important to have a useful perception of
reality than an accurate perception of
reality but of course in in many cases
an accurate perception of reality is a
useful perception of reality and so it's
important to try to figure out what you
know what reaction what reality actually
looks like and to try to cut through
your the illusions and try to cut
through your biases and and make sure
that you're not friend
since confusing correlation for
causation so that's something that to
look out for you know if if it looks
like a Cosby did a Willie Cosby or is
there something else that may have
caused both you try to think of other
hypotheses another mistake that we tend
to make is to to selectively look at
evidence or to use motivated reasoning
so if you cherry-pick things in your
environment that that pop out at you and
to tend to support things that you
already believe or things that you want
to believe
then maybe you should try to find
disconfirming evidence great thank you
so much for being with us
today Matt and we invite our big think
audience to check out the seven laws of
magical thinking how irrational beliefs
keep us happy healthy and sane and
please check back to Big Think calm to
watch additional video clips from our
conversation with Matt Hudson and to
find out about future live interviews
with our experts thanks for watching and
Matt Hudson thank you so much for being
here thanks for having me
you